non
[Musique]
abbassi non bah si quand même cinq ans
bah non un petit peu non
[Rires]
monsieur le directeur oui même pas cap
de regarder ce qui est sur la table
regardez
[Musique]
troll
et faut arrêter de filmer bien même si
je te pendre un truc on se connaît
depuis des années maintenant
une fois de temps en temps pour moi tu
pourrais juste embêté compliqué c'est
compliqué genre dangereux coisy c'est sa
voisine
[Musique]
ilike big box en guise
le haut
couleurs hommage au long des vingt ans
fête des mômes je suis dégoûté mes
enfants viennent de matières mac elle ne
m'aime pas elles viennent on est juste
magnifique
c'est exactement ce que j'aime dire